haben außerirdische schon längst die
erde besucht ein forschungsteam hat sich
jetzt mit dieser frage beschäftigt und
eine lösung gefunden denn ein umstand
wurde bisher noch nicht berücksichtigt
und er kann viele szenarien bedeutend
von sie waren da über sie kommen noch
bis zu
sie haben die ganze galaxie besiedelt
was für welches szenario spricht jetzt
endlich zum science fiction gibt es die
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktive die glocken und dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen über das so genannte vermint
paradoxon hat nun jeweils im science
fiction ausführlich berichtet doch
dieses thema ist einfach immer wieder
aktuell kurz gesagt es geht um die frage
warum wir trotz intensiver suche noch
immer keine hinweise auf intelligentes
außerirdisches leben gefunden haben
intelligente außerirdische müssten doch
in der lage sein die gesamte galaxie zu
kolonisieren oder und dann müssten wir
doch über entsprechende hinweise nur so
stolpern dem ist aber nicht so folgt
daraus also die schlussfolgerung dass es
keine intelligenten außerirdischen gibt
dass unsere ganze suche nach ihnen von
vornherein erfolglos ist und war dann
auch dieses gedankenexperiment soll
dafür sind ja in rico fermi im januar
seit 50 aufgestellt haben sein fazit wer
is everybody dass wir trotz intensiver
suche keinerlei spuren von
außerirdischen leben finden sei einfach
nur paradox und so sei es höchste zeit
unsere annahmen dazu oder aber unsere
beobachtungen in diesem zusammenhang zu
hinterfragen bis heute beschäftigen sich
forschungsteam weltweit mit dem
vermieter boxer ein spannender ansatz
ist beispielsweise die sogenannte zu
hypothese demnach haben außerirdische
zivilisationen uns schon vor langer zeit
entdeckt dann aber beschlossen keinen
kontakt mit uns aufzunehmen und zwar zu
unserem schutz
ähnlich also wie wir es mit
naturschutzgebieten hand haben demnach
beobachten uns ebenso wie wir
beispielsweise robben im wattenmeer von
weiten bestaunen aufgestellt wurde diese
idee im jahr 1973 von dem
radioastronomen john ball vom
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit
doch jetzt gibt es einen neuen ansatz
und eine neue mögliche lösung bezüglich
des fermi paradox 1 1 us forschungsteam
kommt zu dem ergebnis dass sich aliens
die nötige zeit lassen um uns auf der
erde zu besuchen
demnach könnte das intelligente
außerirdischen lebens strategisch
vorgehen
und auf einen günstigen zeitpunkt für
den start ihrer reise zu uns zu warten
dazu der informatiker besonders und
carol möllenbeck der an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war
wenn sich die bewegung der sterne bei
der lösung des problems nicht
berücksichtigen haben sie im grunde
genommen eine von zwei lösungen entweder
verlässt niemand seinen planeten oder
wir sind die einzige technologischen
zivilisationen in der galaxie frühere
untersuchungen zu dem thema hätten nicht
bedacht dass sterne und planeten das
zentrum der galaxie umkreisen unser
sonnensystem beispielsweise braucht rund
230 millionen jahre um die galaxie zu
umkreisen ein guter zeitpunkt für den
start der reise wäre beispielsweise wenn
ihre umlaufbahnen sie einen bewohnbaren
sternensystem näher bringt nach ihrem
besuch dort stünde demnach vielleicht
wieder eine gewisse wartezeit an wie sie
ihrem nächsten ziel näher kommen nämlich
dann wenn sich die reise strecke zum
nächsten system wiederum als optimal
herausstellt und die reisezeit somit von
möglichst kurzer dauer ist das bedeutet
dass gestirne sternensysteme sich nah
sein müssen damit die zivilisationen
sich gegenseitig kontaktieren können
vielleicht haben uns also diese
zivilisation schon längst erreicht und
das vielleicht sogar bevor es überhaupt
menschen gab oder aber sie sind auch bei
der planung ihrer reise und dem besuch
steht früher oder später an der
aktuellen studie zufolge bewegen sich
die außerirdischen also nicht aktiv
durch die galaxie sondern eher passiv
indem sie nur lange genug darauf warten
bis ihr stern in die nähe eines anderen
sterns mit bewohnbaren planeten kommt
dazu der forscher kern allen weg wenn
eine milliarde lang genug sind dann ist
das eine lösung für das fermi paradoxon
boden barren welten sind so selten dass
man länger warten muss als von jeder
zivilisation erwartet bis eine andere in
reichweite kommt in ihren untersuchungen
nutzte das forschungsteam numerische
modelle um die ausbreitung einer
zivilisation in der galaxie zu
simulieren in ihre überlegungen haben
die fachleute viele verschiedene
faktoren einbezogen unter anderem die
geschwindigkeit und reichweite
interstellarer sonnen außen vor aber
blieb die motivation des intelligenten
außerirdischen lebens werden die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wollten ein modell entwickeln das
möglichst wenige annahmen zur soziologie
solcher potenziellen zivilisation mit
einschließt das ergebnis ist
überraschend denn trotz dieser
einschränkung zeigen die modelle da
die milchstraße voller bewohnt das
sternensystem sein könnte die uns
bislang noch unbekannt sind dazu
personellen weg jedes system könnte
bewohnbar und besiedelt sein aber sie
würden uns nicht besuchen weil sie nicht
nah genug sind
auch wenn bislang auf dem 4000
entdeckten planeten außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems keine intelligenten
lebewesen entdeckt wurden hat das nicht
viel zu bedeuten im gegenteil denn
schließlich hätten wir noch nicht genau
genug gesucht denn in der milchstraße
gibt es mindestens 100 milliarden sterne
und noch mehr planeten zehn milliarden
planeten davon könnten sogar ehrt
ähnlich sein
somit haben wir bislang nur einen
klitzekleinen teil genau abgesucht die
behauptung dass kein planet
außerirdisches leben beherbergt
verwerflich und vergleichbar mit der
aussage dass es in den ozean keine
delfine gibt obwohl nur ein kleiner teil
des meeres unter die lupe genommen wurde
nur weil wir bislang noch keine hinweise
auf frühere besucher solcher
zivilisationen auf der erde aufgespürt
haben heißt es laut der aktuellen studie
keineswegs dass diese nie auf der erde
zu besuch waren im gegenteil vielleicht
waren sich schon längst bei uns und die
beweise dafür sind zusammen mit den
dinosauriern von der erde verschwunden
möglicherweise waren außer und das aber
auch schon einmal in unserer direkt nähe
haben sich dann aber dagegen entschieden
uns einen besuch abzustatten vielleicht
wollen sie lieber abstand zu planeten
halten auf denen leben bereits existiert
in ihren simulationen ging das us
forschungsteam davon aus dass fremde
zivilisationen nur einige wenige
bewohnbare welten besuchen würden diese
antreffen
trotz dieser annahme könnte sich laut
der studie intelligentes außerirdisches
leben bereits in der gesamten galaxie
ausgebreitet haben die fachleute sind
optimistisch dass wir demnächst bei
unserer suche erfolgreich sein werden
die derzeitige stille im universum sei
nicht überzubewerten dazu kern allen weg
das ist bedeutet nur dass bewohnbare
planeten wahrscheinlich seltener und
schwer zu erreichen sind
zukünftige teleskope können uns bei
unserer suche enorm unterstützen
beispielsweise das james webb
weltraumteleskop das ja schon bald
starten soll bis dahin wird das fermi
paradox uns sicherlich weiter zur
hitzigen diskussionen führen neue studie
zeigt wir finden aliens wenn sie
leuchten anklicken anschauen und neugier
zu abonnieren sehr sehr sehr cooler
kanal bis dann bleibt dran